so are you surprised sometimes when you
watch the marvel movies like you're in
are you surprised are you ever cause
y'all don't get to see everything right
yes no i i i think especially because i
come from avengers land that becomes
even more secretive and they if you want
to if you want to read it you have to
read it on an ipad or at least for me i
had to i don't know what your privilege
was and and then it started to be that i
only got my own pages and so i have no
idea what i mean
when we filmed infinity war we showed up
to set at the end of the movie
and they said okay so the script pages
are wrong you guys are all going to turn
to dust
sorry for people who haven't seen it but
it was a very long time ago it's your
fault at this point like whatever
so you got there thinking you were and
then you found out you were gonna go to
into dust yes they told us this like on
the day and we all were just ready to
shoot that day and we're like okay well
i guess and they're like i guess i just
die yeah i guess we're just gonna
disintegrate
i i was so shocked at that i'm so
excited i love how i love how these
movies unfold
[Music]